eines tages darüber messer an ein
leckeres erdbeermarmeladenbrot mit honig
sie machte extrem scharfes hippies von
sich aber das erdbeermarmeladenbrot mit
honig wollt ihr einfach nicht aus dem
kopf gehen hallo leute ich jetzt wieder
eure mal waren willkommen zu einer neuen
folge wie speck heute machen wir 1000 m
laden droht mit honig und für die
letztes mal gefragt haben das hier ist
mitglied von den skateboards und das
sind auch mit rick süße katzenbabys
nachdem wir letztes mal mit spaghetti
targus so ein kompliziertes rezept
hatten dachte ich mir dass wir heute mal
ist ein einfacheres machen und alles was
mehrere milliarden grund mit honig
brauchen ist brot und natürlich das vom
glauben die ecke da ist immer mein boot
holen werden denn die eltern marmelade
aus toms erdbeermarmeladenbrot mit honig
wird nur aus erdbeeren gemacht und zu
guter letzt natürlich honig da habe ich
leider keine bienen gefunden die mir auf
meinen erdbeermarmeladenbrot spucken
können denn heute ist mal gesehen habt
in der serie sendung sport und dann hat
er immer ohne ein gutes glas voll
kriegen spucke in dieser sendung geht
trommel markt erst zum müller und gibt
ihnen so ein lässiges halbfertig das mal
aufgefallen ist sehr lässig aus nur 1
müller erste probe für mich manchmal gut
manchmal nicht aber wir haben jetzt brot
und davon lassen wir uns eine dicke
scheibe abschneiden diese cooking skills
sich netz zeit rausholen
angefangen mit spaghetti con und jetzt
muss ich schnell
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt unsere brotscheibe was
sehr kompliziert war beide male hat
weiter für den erdbeeren um die müssen
erst mal gewaschen werden und dann muss
der strom abgeschnitten werden und dann
müssen wir sie zerquetschen denn so
machen wie es in der sendung das ist für
sie hat der marmelade
da gehen wir mal zu dieser ehre
und dann kommt das krokodil bei der us
international lage sei quatsch oder
sowas und dann starten wir die er bernd
und das ist dann die ballade ich weiß
dass marmelade eigentlich anders ist da
gehört noch ein bisschen mehr
arbeitsplätzen fauler sack oder die
wärme laden maus ist eine faule
erdbeeren waschen
egal was ihr mit erdbeer macht ihm ist
sie vorher immer probieren gibt keinen
grund dafür jetzt nehmen uns noch ein
berg kommt abschneiden
und so sollte eure er wäre dann
auswählen ich weiß nicht warum aber ich
finde erdbeeren sind die schönsten
früchte die es gibt zum erbrechen
einfach toll aus so das supermodel
drückten die stimmung ist ex topmodel
ich schaue es wieder und diskotheken ja
also ich mag es zu gucken und das
gefällt mir auf irgendeine art aber ich
mache ja auch mal ziemlich lustig
darüber also weiß ich mich ob ich das
gucken mich lustig zu machen oder weil
ich mir für mich gewählt ist so eine
hassliebe ich kann mich haben sich
ganzen stadt jetzt haben sie erdbeeren
und müssen sie zerquetschen schneidet
ein bisschen klein ich unbedingt mal
meine freunde probieren nicht machen
beste erdbeertorte der welt gehalten
oder haben immer noch sehr viel bei
sendung so wie er will ohne dass man
immer für erwachsene noch so kleine
hitze lässt dass es irgendwie auch für
erwachsene lustig sein kann sein aber
jetzt von sport1 deutschland als
erwachsener gucken oder als kind jeder
jeder kann ich von sport gucken am
liebsten möchte er sein bis der zucker
drauf machen das einfach so ist gut dass
ich auch was meist angezogen habe wenn
ich mit der band zusammenarbeit ich
arbeite und eltern zusammen dass meine
arbeitskollegen
es wird schon immer maschine
ich habe ihn vor ort wie ackermann lade
gemacht also sind führte er
gestartet mit meiner kraft und das
kommissbrot trophy haben wir euch als
letzter von trott kommt der ton ist mit
diesem fest daran wo nicht genommen weil
die masse ja auch mal so fest ist aber
ich krieg eigentlich diesen perfekten
ball dann hole ich das schaffe ich nicht
aber ich kann ja versuchen gut doch ich
nehme jetzt einfach so ein löffel und
legt ihm so betrachtet sollte sie
eigentlich genau so aussehen
oh mein gott leute ich raste aus ich
raste aus es sich perfekt aus schaut
euch das ist der hammer und bedrohlich
und jetzt dass wir uns natürlich wieder
der allerwichtigste frage stellen wie
schmeckt dass er im laden droht mit
honig ist das etwa die gruppe mit sei
heute kam ja klar ist und die aßen beide
einheimischer marmeladenbrot mit honig
und es schmeckte so gut wie ein ganzes
bild rahel oder das erbgut mit honig von
tomtom landen und mit honig schmeckt
diese freude wie schmeckt gefallen hat
einen daumen nach oben da und wenn ihr
noch mehr folgen sehen wollte da sind
bestimmt noch welche
und wenn ihr noch eine katze sehen wollt
vorgestellt dann haben wir noch mehr
kerzen für euch katzen katzen
ich möchte jetzt nicht fertig da sollten
uns unsere werke abonniert
ich liebe meine wandern